welcome to the presentation on using the
quadratic equation so the quadratic
equation it sounds like something very
complicated and when you actually first
see the quadratic equation you'll say
well not only does it sound like
something complicated but it is
something complicated but hopefully
you'll see over the course of this
presentation that it's actually not hard
to use and in a future presentation I'll
actually show you how it was derived so
in general you've already learned how to
factor a second degree equation you've
learned that if I had say x squared
minus X mmm x squared minus X let's make
that a minus ignoring that minus 6
equals 0 if I have this equation x
squared minus X minus 6 equals 0 that
you could factor that as X minus 3 and X
plus 2 equals 0 which either means that
X minus 3 equals 0 or X plus 2 equals 0
so X minus 3 equals 0 or X plus 2 equals
0 so x equals 3 or negative 2 and a
graphical representation of this would
be if I had this is my very badly drawn
graph and if I had the function f of X
is equal to x squared minus X minus 6 so
this axis is the f of X axis you might
be more familiar with the y axis and for
these for the purpose of this type of
problem it doesn't matter and this is
the x axis and if I were to graph this
equation x squared minus X minus 6 it'll
look something like this I'll be it like
this is f of X equals minus 6 and the
graph will kind of do something like
this I'll go up it'll keep going up in
that direction and I know it goes
through minus 6 because when x equals 0
f of X is equal to minus 6 so I know
goes through this point and I know that
when f of X is equal to 0 so f of X is
equal to 0 along the X ax
right right because this is 1 this is 0
this is negative 1 so this is where f of
X is equal to 0 along this x-axis right
and we know it equals 0 at the point X
is equal to 3 and X is equal to minus 2
that's actually what we solved here
maybe when we were doing the factoring
problems you didn't realize kind of
graphically what we were doing but if we
said that f of X is equal to this
function we're setting that equal to 0
so we're saying this function when does
this function equal to 0 when is it
equal to 0 well it's equal to 0 at these
points right because look this is where
f of X is equal to 0 and then what we
were doing when we solve this by
factoring is we figured out the x values
that made f of X is equal to 0 which is
these two points and just a little
terminology these are also called the
zeroes or the roots of f of X let's
review that a little bit so if I had
something like f of X is equal to x
squared plus 4x plus 4 and I asked you
where are the zeros or the roots of f of
X that's the same thing as saying where
does f of X intersect the x axis and it
intersects the x axis when f of X is
equal to 0 right if you think about that
graph I had just drawn so let's say if f
of X is equal to 0 then we could just
say 0 is equal to x squared plus 4x plus
4 and we know we could just factor that
that's X plus 2 times X plus 2 and we
know that 0 it's equal to 0 at x equals
-2
x equals minus 2 well that's that's a
little x equals minus 2 so now we know
how to find the zeros when the the
actual equation is easy to factor but
let's do a situation where the equation
is actually not so easy to factor let's
say we had f of X is equal to minus 10 x
squared minus 9x plus 1 well when I look
at this even if I were divided by 10 I
would get some fractions here it's very
hard to imagine factoring this quadratic
and that's why it's actually called the
quadratic equation or this second-degree
polynomial but let's set it so we're
trying to solve this because we want to
find out where N equals 0 minus 10 x
squared minus 9x plus 1 we want to find
out what X values make this equation
equal to 0 and here we can use a tool
called a quadratic equation and now I'm
going to give you one of the few things
in math that's probably good idea to
memorize the quadratic equation says
that the roots of a quadratic are equal
to and let's say that the quadratic
equation is a x squared plus BX plus C
equals 0 so in this example a is minus
10 B is minus 9 and C is 1 the formula
is the roots x equals negative b plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4 times a times C all of that over 2a I
know that looks complicated but the more
you use it you'll see it's actually not
that bad
and this is a good idea to memorize so
let's apply the quadratic equation to
this equation that we just wrote down so
I just said and look a is just the
coefficient on the X term right B is
just the coefficient a is the
coefficient of the x squared term B is a
coefficient on the X term
and C is the constant so let's apply it
to this equation what's B well B is
negative 9 right we can see here B is
negative 9 a is negative 10 C is 1 right
so if B is negative 9 so let's say
that's negative negative 9 plus or minus
the square root of negative 9 squared
well that's 81 minus 4 times a a is
minus 10 minus 10 times C which is 1 I
know this is messy but I hopefully
you're understanding it and all of that
over 2 times a well a is minus 10 so 2
times a is minus 20 right so let's
simplify that negative times negative 9
that's positive 9 plus or minus the
square root of 81 we have a negative 4
times a negative 10 this is a minus 10
and it's very messy I really apologize
for that times 1 so negative 4 times
negative 10 is 40 positive 40 positive
40 and then we have all of that over
negative 20
well 81 plus 40 is 121 so this is 9 plus
or minus the square root of 121 over
minus 20 square root of 121 is 11 so
I'll go here hoping you don't lose track
of what I'm doing this is 9 plus or
minus 11 over minus 20 and so if we did
so if we said 9 plus 11 over minus 20
that is 9 plus 11 is 20 so this 20 over
minus 20 which equals negative 1 so
that's one root that's 9 plus because
this is plus or minus and then the other
root would be 9 minus 11 over negative
20 which equals my minus 2
/ - 20 which equals 1 over 10 so that's
the other root so if we were to graph
this equation we would see that it
actually intersects the x-axis or f of X
equals 0 at the point x equals negative
1 and x equals 1/10 I'm going to do a
lot more examples in part two because I
think if anything I might have just
confused you with this one
so I'll see you in the part two of using
the quadratic equation